les trois yvelinois sont toujours en
course pour ce vendée globe 2016 les
versaillais tanguy de lamotte éric
bellion et laurent politain louis burton
sont au large de l'afrique après être
parti le 6 novembre dernier des sables
d'olonne pour ce tour du monde en
solitaire et sans escale
classé à la neuvième place mercredi
dernier tanguy de lamotte avait le
sourire au début de l'aventuré à bord
d'initiative coeur on vient de passer la
zone interdite du dst du cap finistère
et on à hisser le gennaker avec les
dauphins
bon après midi et bonne soirée à tous
c'est parti pour le tour du monde y est
mais le ver seuil et a vite déchanté son
imoca initiative coeur a été victime
d'une avarie sur la tête de masse ce
dimanche au large du cap-vert évinois dû
réparer lui-même les dégâts en train de
pêcher la voile et surtout la bonne
nouvelle c'est qu'elle est là la voile
elle est plus dans la quille ça c'est
bon ça voilà avoir d'abord elle est plus
dans la quille d'un commun l'impression
de déjà vu cette partie de pêche
au pointage de 15 heures ce lundi 14
novembre tanguy de lamotte occupe la 20e
place du classement de son côté éric
bellion sur comme un seul homme est
installé à la 25e position pour son
premier vendée globe le skipper garde le
moral
là depuis trois jours j'ai eu les
problèmes que kim terrorisé plus avant
de partir vers ce vendée globe j'ai eu
grand gennaker
il s'est déroulé dans vincent 9 ans
alors que cela fallait hier soir j'ai
fait
depuis j'ai fait un départ à l'abattée
avec le gennaker à contre couché sur
l'eau toutes les sauces et vraiment
c'est ce qui faisait le plus peur est en
fait ce que je veux vous dire c'est que
ça sert à rien d'avoir peur en fait on a
peur d'avoir peur ça s'est bien passé
j'ai trouvé les solutions
le troisième yvelinois louis burton qui
avait dû abandonner en 2012 suite à une
collision avec un chalutier est pour
l'instant la 14e place sur son imoca
bureau vallée pour tenir le skipper
communique avec sa famille at on va vite
moi je suis en pleine forme vous me
manquez beaucoup beaucoup je n'arrête
pas de regarder des photos et je vais
mettre une petite chanson pour qu'on
danse tous ensemble vous 3 la maison et
puis moi dans le bateau allez on va
d'abord mes amours
cette huitième édition du vendée globe
est toujours dominé par le britannique
alex thomson sur hugo boss
les premiers ne sont pas attendu aux
sables d'olonne avant deux mois et demi